um I'm Willow this was a workshop on
spherical uh spinning and body bouncing
to unrelated technically subjects but
related for me personally because I
really like sensation based spinning my
purpose of spinning spherically is to
try flow without Tech conventions um I
love Tech conventions and Frameworks
that involve like grid patterns and
stuff and there's also uh kind of flow
that are just like sensation based so
that's uh my style of spherical spinning
uh to start I showed this weave which is
kind of like a this backwards I guess
people call it a 1 and 1/2 weave and
it's like that hand to hand and it's
swaye back and forth a
lot uh this is really nice cuz you can
fall into it from anything and you can
really use it to get into most timing
and
directions um
yeah and then we started talking about
touches which was a lot of the focus of
the workshop touches are this it's kind
of the first basic touch is doing that
same weave but kind of down at the
tethers letting the tethers
meet
um so this is the first touch weave that
we covered the reason they're called
touches is because they're not
technically
Tangles um just real fast that's the
shape that you're going for it's kind of
threedimensional
and they kind of like that's the Apex of
it this point right here which is not
technically a tangle anything past it
would be considered a tangle so that's a
tangle tangle tangle tangle up to that
point and then from this point onward to
here and all that stuff is non-tangle so
with touches you're playing with uh
these portions of tether's meeting from
here to here and with Tangles you're
playing these portions from here to
here so with
touches talked about how to get into
them how you use this pendulum bending
it and then striking up on the tether
with the other
tether uh with this first basic touch
you can add a lot of variation and
separate your
arms make it really huge
and almost feels and looks like an
entirely different thing uh you can do
it really fast and it feels and looks
like an entirely different thing you can
also isolate it which just gets all
kinds of
funky and the that's another sort of
line of reasoning because that gets into
the hand path which is spherical as
well okay and then there's the different
kinds of touches so that's the first
basic one there's ones with sort of more
degrees of twist this is kind of like a
five beish sort of move move it's not a
5 5ish though um I like this cuz you can
meet the heads close together and then
move that connection Point down close to
your hand and it's a really nice
sensation have
it coming back towards you there's like
forward
versions touches as
well um this
one
this
[Music]
one so those are the four standard like
touch
weaves and then I sort of talked about
this uh sensation based style of
spinning where a toroid which is just a
spherical shape moving through space or
by a larger like mathematical convention
a donut shape uh if you take that sphere
moving through space that's how I like
to flow with spherical spinning I will
say goodbye to planes and kind of just
move around around in space and we
talked about this move as well which is
just a simple tangle and
bounce and how you can move with it sort
of take that moving toroid through your
body you can even trace it
over there's little kinds of weird
traces you can do with
it um yeah and then what else are we
talk talked about the really important
aspect of spherical spinning of this
pendulum and how it's very dense
transition state so when you go into a
pendulum you can use it to fall 90° away
on another vertical plane or you can
pull it from a vertical plane directly
into a floor plane so in that moment you
can choose floor plane or vertical plane
you can do either or you can take it
straight into isolations it can be a
point for
any thing so using that in these touch
patterns is really important especially
for starting to incorporate touches into
Tangles you can be doing touches fall
directly into Tangles and out of them
again
can at any point that you're in a tangle
you can just weave directly into a
touch um and vice
versa okay and then we started covering
uh body bouncing a little bit
which is different subject but uh the
first thing we looked at is how to
double bounce like
this um that's just a slow hand movement
from one side to the other while the boy
does a double
bounce first pattern with that we looked
at is this really
nice slow and flowy
one to drill in it doing it on both
hands and we mentioned also so how you
can do this double bounce on the
back looked at moves like this really
straightforward simple
one and
um we looked at like this double bounce
here noticing that any double bounce
that you do as you're moving with uh PO
on the floor plane any double bounce you
do will switch which hand you're leading
there's only two timing with this stuff
left hand leading and right hand leading
and any double bounce you do will switch
which one is
leading uh which else did we look at
looked at applying like double bounces
to
Superman's for example this just take a
standard Superman and add double bounces
into
it it's really fun to incorporate with
threep
stuff and
and I think that was it we did a couple
more body bouncing things that I can't
remember the hand thing with
the yes this was one of them that bounce
points there's a lot of others actually
there's like
these uh shoulder
ones see there's that one there there's
a lot of interesting elbow stuff
too throwing all them together is really
fun
cuz you end up
with uh you can end up with extra
degrees of
twist like that some really weird
points yeah I think uh I think that's
pretty much it yeah yeah